I feel like we're a little too quick to
apply AI especially when it comes to
deep neural networks just because of how
effective they are when we throw a lot
of data and computation at them and so
much so that we might even be
overlooking what the best human baseline
is you might not even be comparing
against the best human baseline so a lot
of what this agenda is trying to do is
try to push the human limit as far as it
can and then kind of integrate AI at
where it makes sense to do that you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen using
[Applause]
dr. Siddhartha Sen is a principal
researcher in MSRs New York City lab and
his research interests are if not
impossible at least impossible sounding
optimal decision-making Universal data
structures and verifiably safe AI today
he tells us how he's using reinforcement
learning and hybrid algorithms to tap
the best of both human and machine
intelligence and develop AI that's
minimally disruptive synergistic with
human solutions and safe madam much more
on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast Sid Sen welcome to the
podcast thank you so fun to have you
here today
you're a principal researcher at the MSR
lab in New York City which is a lab with
a really interesting history and mission
but since research is constantly moving
and evolving why don't you tell us
what's new in the Big Apple from your
perspective what big questions are you
asking these days and what big problems
are you trying to solve as a unit there
our lab is really unique we have four
main disciplines represented in addition
to what I represent which is systems and
machine learning and systems we have a
machine learning group we have a
computational social science group we
have an economics and computation group
and we have a faith group which is this
new group on fairness accountability
transparency and ethics and you know I
would say that if I had to sum up the
kind of work we're doing and a lot of us
work on decision-making decision-making
with opportunities and under certain
kinds of constraints and I think a lot
of the work we're talking about today is
is trying to understand where
computation and in particular artificial
intelligence can help us and where it's
not so strong and where you know the
more human approach is more appropriate
or is even better and then trying to
figure out a way for these things to
work together so that's gonna be a very
core kind of a theme in and what we're
gonna talk about the word hybrid is
gonna come up a lot in our conversation
today but in different ways with
different spellings so let's start with
your own hybrid nature
and talk about what gets you up in the
morning tell us about your personal
research passions and how you bring what
I would call hybrid vigor to the
research gene pool so I think I've
always been a bit interdisciplinary in
everything I've done and ever since I've
kind of grown up I've always been able
to do like a lot of different things
reasonably well and so you can imagine I
always questioned myself in terms of how
much depth I had in anything right I
even questioned myself throughout my PhD
when I went to do my PhD I was
co-advised and more systems oriented
work as well as theoretical work at two
different advisers and I essentially
ended up doing two separate PhDs because
I couldn't quite get those two
disciplines to gel well together it's
very hard to do that and you know a lot
of students have asked me I want to do
what you did and I said yes that that's
a nice idea in principle but it's not so
easy to synergize to different areas
since then I think I've kind of figured
out how to do that so how to kind of
leverage and appreciate the breadth I
have and the appreciation I have for
different disciplines and make these
things work together I figured out how
to synergize ideas from different
disciplines to solve bigger problems
problems like you know how do we use AI
responsibly in our systems how do we
leverage what humans are good at or how
do we keep things safe and I think these
kinds of problems are not problems you
can solve with expertise in one area in
one field and so a lot of what I figured
out how to do is how to bring these
different ideas together and work with
different colleagues to bring these
solutions out well your current research
mission is to and I quote optimize cloud
infrastructure decisions with AI in a
way that's as you call it minimally
disruptive synergistic with human
solutions and safe and to do this you've
got three correlated research agendas
which I'll have you dig into shortly but
before we do that I want to go upstream
a bit and talk about the conceptual
framework for your work which we might
call reinforcement learning in real life
or RL IRL give us a rationale for this
framework and then we'll get technical
on how you're going about it I think a
lot of AI is going to be this kind of
gradual integration into the background
of our lives into the systems that we
use so I think it's important to first
see how
much we can learn and how much we can do
without disrupting existing systems just
by kind of observing what they're doing
now without having to change them so
much what can we do to learn as much as
we can from what they're doing and to
kind of even reason about what would
happen if we tried different things if
we used AI in different ways without
actually changing what they're doing so
that's why I want to take this minimally
disruptive approach then at the same
time I think it's important to
understand where AI should fit in
because if you just come in barging in
with an AI solution that is not
something that's so easily digestible by
existing systems and you know processes
that we have in place and so
understanding where the AI is good where
it should fit in where the human
solutions are good and finding a way
that they can complement each other is
something that to me is critical to
ensuring that you can gradually make
this change and then finally when you do
make the change you know how do you
maintain people's trust and how do you
keep things safe you know I don't think
AI and humans are ever going to be held
to the same standards even if an AI
system statistically affects or harms
fewer people than a human operator would
they're still going to be held to a
different kind of standard and so I
think it's all trials are important once
we make this kind of change to try to
keep things safe well let's talk and
turn now about the three research
agendas or roadmaps we might call them
that you're following on the road to
optimal decisions online so the first
one is something you call harvesting
randomness and this one takes on the
minimally disruptive challenge so why
don't you start by giving us a level set
on the problem and then tell us all
about harvesting randomness and how the
idea of counterfactual evaluation is
gaining traction in reasoning about
systems this project kind of came out of
a simple observation one thing I
observed was that whenever we want to
try something new we'll figure out how
something new is going to work we often
have to deploy it and try it out this is
what we call an a/b test and people use
it all over the place they use it in
medical trials they use it online at any
given time when you're using you know
being or Google or any service you're
seeing something different than what I'm
seeing because they're continuously
trying out different things by deploying
these live a B tests
and the reason that works is because
they randomized what people see and
because they randomized what people see
they can evaluate how good different
alternative solutions are and avoid any
kind of biases or confounding issues
that might come into place and I
realized that randomness is all over the
place we ran to my stuff all the time
like when we load balanced requests when
we decide where to replicate or put data
when we decide what to do if too many
people are trying to do the same thing
at the same time we make these
randomized decisions all the time and I
thought what if I could you know harvest
all of that randomness to do all of
these experiments without actually
having to do the experiments so that's
in essence what counterfactual
evaluation or kind of factual reasoning
is what if I had done this can I answer
that question without actually running a
big AP test and exposing the world to it
because that's risky and that's costly
and so that was the theory behind this
project is that where I'm going to go
around to all these systems that are
already doing all this randomized stuff
and using a slightly different set of
statistical techniques I can maybe
answer questions about what would have
happened if I tried this other policy
and that way I could you know without
disrupting or changing the system reason
about what would have happened if I
changed things and I think it turns out
that it's not as easy to do that as we
thought it would be and the reason is
all these systems that are randomized
are very complicated and stateful
systems we don't really have good enough
practical techniques to understand them
but what we have found is that and the
systems that surround us there's a lot
of information that's similar to the
kind of information you would get from
randomization that's already just
sitting there and I call that implicit
feedback and this is something that
we're trying to leverage
it's kind of a very simple concept in
systems but when you wait for something
to happen and we do that all the time in
systems you know we're waiting for some
event to happen if you wait for five
minutes it turns out you find out what
would have happened if you waited for
four minutes or three minutes or two
minutes or if you provide a resource to
someone you give them 10 cores or 10
virtual machines you might find out what
would have happened if you gave them
nine or eight or seven because you gave
them more than those numbers and so
because of this kind of implicit
structure we're able to look
a lot of the decisions that existing
systems are making now and we're able to
say oh look here are situations where
they're actually making decisions where
we could answer the counterfactual
question of what would have happened if
they made smaller decisions can we
leverage that feedback to learn more
from that existing data and then using
that information come up with better
policies for making those decisions so
it's not the same as like the natural
randomness that we started out initially
envisioning we could harvest but it's
similar because it gives us the same
kind of information and now that we have
a technique for harvesting this extra
feedback we can basically take this
feedback you know use probabilities to
weight things in the right way so that
we get what I call an unbiased view of
the world and you know this way we can
kind of find a better policy to put in
there without actually changing the
system that much at all so what kind of
results are you getting with this are
you using it or deploying it in places
where it would matter yeah so one of the
teams that we've worked with for a while
is the team that deals with you know
unhealthy machines in Azure what happens
when you can contact a machine it's
unresponsive what do you do how long do
you wait for it and how long should I
wait for that machine to come back alive
or should I just go ahead and reboot it
recycle it and put it back into the
pipeline or the process of what we call
our fabric controller that takes
machines and recycles them and gets them
ready for production use so that's a
decision where we are able to kind of
harvest existing data that they have to
find a better policy for choosing how
long to wait another example is whenever
you ask Asher for certain number of
virtual machines you say hey give me a
hundred machines they'll actually
allocate more than 100 because they're
not sure if the hundred will succeed and
how long it will take for them to
deliver those hundred to you so they
might say allocate hundred twenty and
they'll just give you the first hundred
that get started up the fastest and so
here's an opportunity where we can
harvest that information because of this
over allocation that implicit
information that's in there to do
something that's much more optimal and
save on the amount of extra unnecessary
work that they have to do when they're
spinning up these large clusters of
virtual machines let's say you wait for
10 minutes and
something happens but you also know what
happened at nine minutes at eight
minutes at seven minutes right so this
is how you're explaining it is it always
gonna happen then at 10 minutes I know
that I'll wait for nine if I just wait
one more minute I'll be fine instead of
having to go to the expense of reading
it's on yeah I think that's a great
point we might not know and one thing
that's unique about the feedback we're
getting is it kind of depends on what
happens in the real world I might wait
for five minutes and you know nothing
happened in that situation I only
learned what would have happened if I
waited less than that amount of time but
I don't learn anything about what would
have happened if I waited longer than
that amount of time whereas sometimes if
I wait for five minutes the Machine
comes up in two minutes and now I know
everything I know all the information
that would have happened if I had waited
for one minute or two minutes or ten
minutes or nine minutes or whatever it
is so there is kind of an asymmetry in
the kind of feedback you get back and
this is a place where existing
counterfactual techniques fall short
they're not able to deal with this kind
of the different amount of feedback you
get which depends on the outcome of what
actually plays out in the real world and
so this is where we have to do most of
our innovation on the you know the
statistical and reinforcement learning
side to develop a commercial to think
that word for this scenario right and
you know I should say that this work is
something that we see come up in many
different system decisions across our
cloud infrastructure anytime we're
allocating any resource whether that
resources time machines memory cores
anytime we're doing that
there's the simplicity information that
we should be harvesting it's like a crop
that we're not harvesting and there's an
opportunity cost to not doing that and
so part of the goal of this work is to
show people that there is that
opportunity there but also to kind of
show them how we can leverage this in a
principled way so that our system
designers know how they can design their
systems in a way that allows them to
continuously evolve them and optimize
them and a lot of what this harvesting
randomest work is showing you how to do
is how do I in a statistically correct
way collect data and improve my system
collect more data and improve my system
and keep doing this because the way
we're doing it now is not actually you
know fully correct
no one can ever see the grin that I have
on my face
also on a podcast people can't see how
things are spelled and in the case of
your second research agenda it actually
matters you're developing what you call
hybrid algorithms here we come on the
hybrid and that spelled H AI BR ID so
what are hybrid algorithm said and how
do they move the ball forward in the
world of data structure research so I
always get a snicker - and people see
the spelling of this and I don't know if
that's because it's lame or if it's
because they like it but it's built H AI
because the H stands for human and the
AI stands for a I for artificial
intelligence and so the idea of these
algorithms is to basically find the
right synergy between human and AI
solutions to find the right balance the
right way to use AI and I do strongly
believe in that because I feel like
we're a little too quick to apply AI
especially when it comes to deep neural
networks just because of how effective
they are when we throw a lot of data and
computation at them so much so that we
might even be overlooking what the best
human baseline is you might not even be
comparing against the best human
baseline so a lot of what this agenda is
trying to do is trying to push the human
limit as far as it can and then kind of
integrate AI at where it makes sense to
do that
and we're starting very classical we're
starting as simple as it gets we're
looking at data structures you know
there was a lot of buzz a couple years
ago when folks at Google in MIT were
able to replace classical data
structures with very simple neural
networks a lot of what data structures
are used for is to organize and store
data and so oftentimes you use them by
giving them some kind of key and telling
them hey can you look up this piece of
information find it for me and give it
back to me and they kind of observed
that the key and its position in the
data look like training data for a
machine learning model so why don't we
just shove it into a machine learning
model and make it answer the question
for us and you know they show that if
the data set is fixed it doesn't change
then you can train this kind of layer of
neural network to answer that question
for you
and they can do it way faster using way
less memory than let's say a classical
structure like a b-tree the problem with
a lot of that was the human baselines
they were compared against were not
nearly the best baselines you would use
you wouldn't use this big fat B tree to
find something in a sorted data set that
doesn't change you would use something
very simple like maybe binary search or
some multi-way search that's something
that is way more efficient and doesn't
require much space at all or much time
and so when I saw this work I I thought
about every human baseline they were
comparing against and I felt bad for
those human baselines I said ah that's
not fair these human baselines weren't
designed for that they were designed for
something much more they were designed
for these dynamic changing workloads and
datasets and that's why they're all
bloated and you know inefficient and
there's because they they're keeping
space so that they can accommodate
future stuff right they're not designed
for this particular thing you're looking
at and so we set out to kind of design
what we thought was the best human data
structure for this problem we call it a
little bit presumptuously we call it a
universal index structure and the idea
of this universal index structure is
that it's going to basically give us the
best performance all the time
more concretely what that means is that
I'm going to look at what the workload
looks like now and then I'm going to try
to metamorphose myself into the data
structure that's perfect for that
workload and then I'm going to give it
to you so it sounds like an impossible
thing but you know my Gretchen I think a
lot of the work I do is impossible
sounding at a high level and I kind of
like that because one of the reasons
I've been able to appreciate kind of my
hybrid view of things is that I come up
with a crazier idea or approach than
most people would so something like a
universal data structure to me it sounds
like an impossibility but then what you
can do is you can say okay suppose I had
access to some kind of Oracle some
Supreme Being that gave me for free the
things that I wanted then maybe I could
solve this problem so that's kind of how
I plan my research I say okay if someone
told me what the current workload was
and if someone told me for this workload
what is the best structure to use and if
someone told me how do I go from what I
have now
to this best structure and I got all
these answers for free well then I would
solve my problem and I would just use it
I'd have a universal data structure
right there
so now we go about trying to solve these
Oracle's each of which is hard but you
know when it's a hard Oracle you can
break that down into sub Oracle's and
make a road map for solving that sub
Oracle all right and then the problems
slowly get easier and easier until there
are things that are tractable enough for
you to actually solve and then you can
put the pieces back together and you
have a solution to the higher-level
problem all right
so how you doing that right how are we
doing that so what we're doing now is
we're taking a black box approach we're
taking existing data structures without
changing any of them all the classical
stuff that people use hash tables trees
skip lists radix trees and we're saying
how can I move efficiently from one of
those structures to another so what
we've developed is an efficient
transition mechanism that allows us to
take data from one of these structures
and gradually move it to another
structure if we feel like that other
structure is going to be better at
handling the current workload so we use
some ideas from machine learning to
profile these data structures and to try
to understand what regimes are good at
ok so we are using ml a little bit here
and there when we think it makes sense
so we're trying to understand the space
of when these data structures are good
once we understand that space then we're
trying to come up with a efficient way
to move from one of these data
structures to the other and so the big
innovation of this work is in coming up
with that transition mechanism it's a
way of sorting the data that you're
working with and gradually moving the
data from one structure to another in a
way that you can do piecemeal where you
don't lose your work where you don't
affect the correctness of the queries
that you're trying to respond to people
are going to be continuously asking your
system to answer questions while you're
doing all of this and in a way that it
makes it worthwhile like we try to make
sure that this transition mechanism is
efficient enough that we're actually
getting a benefit from it and if we find
that we're just flopping around all over
the place
we keep moving from data structure A to
B back to a back to C well we check for
that and if that's happening we kind of
back off and say no let's not do that
this is not
worth it right now and so this
transition mechanism is kind of where
most of the innovation has happened it's
a simple transition mechanism because it
just intelligently uses the existing API
is provided by these data structures to
do this kind of transitioning between
them and later on in the future I hope
that we can open up the black box a
little bit and by understanding these
data structures from the inside maybe we
can actually do something even more
intelligent and more efficient let's
talk about a specific example of that
while we're on the topic of hybrid
algorithms one example of some very
current work you're doing involves using
the game of chess as a model system for
bridging the gap between what you call
super human AI and human behavior so
this is really interesting to me on
several levels tell us about it yeah so
where is the universal index structure
was trying to say let's take a pause and
not use ml just yet let's see how far I
can push the human design and find a way
to just you know switch between them and
use all of them in some fluid way so
that I can do as good a job as I can and
then the idea would be how can we then
take that strong human baseline and
improve on that with AI and I think the
verdict is still out there it's still
unclear to me which one's a stronger
force there and how they'll work
together in chess it's a little
different because we actually know today
that chess engines and AI are far
stronger than any kind of human player
can be so just as an example of a task
where AI has surpassed human play and
yet we still continue to play it because
it's fun right a lot of times you'll
find that when AI does better at humans
it'll just take over
it just takes over that job from who was
doing it before whether it was a human
or a human designed algorithm or
heuristic but chess is a game word that
hasn't really happened because we still
play the game we enjoy it so much and so
that's why I think it's an interesting
case study the problem with chess is
that the way humans play and the way
engine play are very very different so
they've kind of diverged and it's not
really fun to play the engine you just
lose just you know lose all the time so
now interestingly people are using the
engines now to train themselves which is
kind of an interesting situation because
it's almost like this subtle
overtaking of AI it's like alright
neural networks our brains are now being
exposed to answers that the engine is
giving us without explanation the engine
just tells you this is the best move
here right it's figured it out it's
explored the game tree it knows AI to
tell you this is the best move when you
okay and then you try to reason why is
that the best move oh I think I kind of
get it okay so a lot of the top just
first today and they spent a lot of time
using the engine to train their own
neural nets inside their brains so I
actually think that our brains our
neural nets they're a product of
everything we put in there and right now
one of the things that they're getting
in as input are answers from the engine
so that's the subtle way that AI is
seeping into your brain and into your
life but going back to what we did I
mean we basically realize that there's
this gap between how da engines play and
how humans play and when there's this
gap maybe the AI engine should be
helping us get better right but right
now we don't have that kind of engine
these engines just tell us what the best
move is they don't have what I would
call a teaching ability and so what
we're trying to do in this project is
trying to bridge that gap we're trying
to come up with an engine that can teach
humans at different levels that can
understand how a weak player plays
understand how a strong player plays and
try to suggest things that they can do
at different levels so we looked at all
the existing chess engines out there
ones that are not based on AI and ones
that are based on AI and we found that
these engines if you try to use them to
predict what humans will do at different
levels they either predict kind of
uniformly well across all of the humans
or they're predictions get better as the
humans get better which means that none
of them really are understanding what
different humans at different levels
play like so what we did was we kind of
took this neural network framework
that's underneath it and we repurposed
it to try to predict what humans would
do and we were able to develop engines
that are good at predicting human moves
at every different level of play so this
is I think a small building block in
getting at this idea of a real like AI
teacher someone who can sit with you
understand where you're at and then from
there maybe suggest things that you
might try that are appropriate for your
level
let's talk about your third research
agenda and it's all about safeguards the
metaphors abound training wheels bumpers
on a bowling alley apparent explain the
problem this research addresses in light
of the reinforcement learning literature
to date and then tell us what you're
doing in this space to ensure that the
RL policies that my AI proposes are
actually safe and reliable yeah so
safety is something that has come up in
all of the things we've talked about it
comes up repeatedly in everything we've
done in the harvesting randomness agenda
you know after harvesting information
and coming up with a better policy every
time we try to deploy something we the
product team or group they always have
some safeguard and place some guardrail
in place
if this happens page me or if this
happens shut this off or things like
that it comes up even in the universal
data structure we've talked about what
happens when I keep flip-flopping around
these different data structures and I'm
wasting all this time and my performance
is going down well maybe I need to put a
break on things and the tests work as
well it happens because one of the
things that the chess teachers trying to
do is prevent the human from walking
into a trap or walking down a path of
moves that they can't handle because
they're not strong enough yet as a
player to handle it and so you can
reason about safe moves versus unsafe
moves and so because I just saw this
cropping up all over the place I
realized it's time to take a step back
and reason about this and formalize this
so this is something that systems people
do which I think they're good at doing
is they see of people doing all kinds of
ad hoc stuff and they say oh this is an
opportunity here to come up with a new
abstraction and so safeguards are that
new abstraction I think the sign of a
good abstraction is it's something that
like everyone is already using it but
they don't know it they don't give it a
name and so if everyone's already doing
something like this in their own ad-hoc
ways what we're trying to do is extract
this component we're calling it a
safeguard and we're trying to say what
is its role so to me a safeguard is
something that kind of sits alongside
any artificially intelligent system that
you have treats it like a black box and
it protects it from making bad decisions
by occasionally overriding its decisions
when it thinks that they're about to
violate some kind of safety
specification
so what is the safety specification well
it can be anything it can be a
performance guarantee that you want it
can be a fairness guarantee maybe it can
even be a privacy guarantee and we
haven't explored all of the realms right
now we've been focusing on performance
guarantees and I think the point is that
if you have this component sitting
outside the AI system it doesn't
necessarily need to understand what that
AI system is doing it just needs to
observe what its decisions are and as
long as it has an idea like the safety
specification it can say oh I think what
you're going to do now is violate the
safety spec so I'm going to override it
but if I see in the future that you're
doing a better job or you're within the
safety realm then I'm going to back off
and I'm not going to change your
decisions so the safeguard is like this
living breathing component that itself
might use artificial intelligence and it
can use AI to adapt it can say oh I see
that this system is doing a good job
okay I'm gonna back off I don't need to
provide that much of a safety buffer but
the moment I see that the system is not
doing a good job then maybe I need to
put the clamp down at the safeguard
we'll say okay I need a big safety
buffer around you and so that's why I
like to think of this analogy of
parenting because I think that that's
what we do with kids a lot in the
beginning you know you're childproof
your house you put training wheels on
bikes and you constrain and restrict a
lot of what they can do and then slowly
you observe that now they're getting
bigger they're falling down less they're
able to handle corners and edges more
and you start removing the bumpers you
might start raising the training wheels
and things like that but maybe you go to
a new house or a new environment or
you're on a vacation and then maybe you
need to clamp down a little bit more
right because you realize that oh
they're in a new environment on they
might start hurting themselves again and
so that's kind of the inspiration behind
this idea of a safe guard that adapts to
the actual system okay so I want to
drill in again on the technical side of
this because I get the metaphor and how
are you doing that technically so what
we're doing now is we're taking some
example systems from the previous work
we talked about and we're hand coding
safeguards based on the safety specs of
those systems someone might say well how
do you even know what a safety spec
should be what we found is that people
usually know what the safety spec is
most of the teams we work with they
usually know what things they check for
what things they monitor that trigger
actions to have
likes guardrails that they have in place
so most of the teams we've talked to
they check for like six different things
and if those six different things exceed
these thresholds they do some big action
so we can usually derive the safety spec
for their systems by talking to the
product team and looking at what they do
right now once we get that we're kind of
hand coding and designing a safeguard
and we're using tools from program
verification to prove that the safeguard
that we code up satisfies what we call
an inductive safety invariant which
means that it satisfies some safety
property and every action that that
safeguard takes will always continue to
be safe so as long as you're in the safe
zone no matter what you do as long as
the safeguard is active and in place you
will stay in the safe zone and so we can
use tools from program verification to
write these safeguards prove that they
satisfied the safety environment then
what we do is we add a buffer to that
safeguard I think of the analogy of like
adding more padding to the bumpers on
the corners of the tables or putting the
training wheels a little lower
so I can use the same kind of
verification approach to verify the
safety of the safeguard plus some kind
of buffer and then what I'll do is I'll
use AI to adapt that buffer depending on
how good the system is doing so now I've
got it to you that everything is going
to be safe even if you have this kind of
buffer okay great and now I can shrink
and grow this buffer you're doing well
the buffer will be really small which is
good for a lot of systems because if you
keep that small buffer it allows systems
to be aggressive and when you're
aggressive you can optimize better you
can use more resources you can push the
systems to their limits a little more
which is good for you but if you're in
situation we're not doing well or
there's some uncertainty or the
environment has change then we kind of
increase that safety buffer and the
whole time you're still guaranteed that
everything is going to be correct so
that's kind of what we have now what I
really want to do again because no
project is worth it if it's not
impossible sounding is to automatically
synthesize these safeguards like we're
coding them by hand now I want to use
fancy program synthesis magic she's
gonna ask you next yeah yeah so that's
that would be ideal like I don't want to
have to sit and do these things by hand
get a safety spec and some structured
information about the application and I
want to automatically synthesize this
safeguard and then show you that it is
and prove that it's correct
so we're working with an amazing
colleague in the program synthesis and
program verification world who is
actually the director of our MSR India
lab Shriram Rajamani
HOD cast he's amazing
not only is amazing he is maybe the
nicest person I know like in the world
he's working with us on this and it's a
lot of fun
I love working on projects where I love
working with the collaborators in fact I
think I find that these days I I tend to
pick projects more based on the
collaborators and the topic sometimes
but this is one where it's both the
topic and the collaborators are are just
a complete thrill and pleasure to work
with and so we're hoping that combining
our techniques I do systems and AI stuff
and reinforcement learning he
understands program synthesis and
verification we have someone who
understands causal inference and
statistics and so with these three
disciplines we're hoping that we can
come up with a way to automatically
synthesize these safeguards so that any
system that is using AI and that has an
idea of what safety means for them can
leverage the safeguard and come up with
one
[Music]
well speaking of collaboration that's a
big deal at Microsoft Research and
you're doing some really interesting
work with a couple of universities and I
don't want to let you go before we talk
at least briefly about two projects one
with NYU related to what systems folks
call provenance and another with Harvard
trying to figure out how to delete
private data from storage systems in
order to comply with GDP are both fall
under this idea of responsible AI which
is a huge deal at Microsoft right now so
without getting super granular though
because we have a couple more questions
I want to cover with you give us a
snapchat story version of these two
projects as well as how they came about
real quick okay yeah so with NYU were
working with two professors they're
professor Jin Yong Li and professor or
rigid panda and two amazing students on
what we're calling ml provenance and so
the idea is can we find and explain the
reasons behind a particular decision
made by an ml model and so there's been
a lot of work on trying to do this and I
think what we've done that's different
is we formulated the problem in a
different way we've said what if there
are different sources of data that go
into training this model so if that was
a case and you have all these different
sources you can look at a particular
decision made by the machine learning
model and say ok what were the sources
that contributed to that decision so it
turns out you can formulate a new
machine learning problem that uses those
sources as the features and as its label
the decision and we can use statistical
techniques to try to narrow down and
zoom in on which of the sources actually
caused that decision so this is going to
be useful for doing things like
detecting poisoning attacks which is a
very common security problem people look
at in machine learning models we with
our technique you can kind of find the
data source that caused you to do that
so that is the other is we can find the
data source that caused that decision or
maybe even find the actual data point in
some cases that caused that decision and
we can do this without training too many
models and the coolest thing about I
think is again this idea of harvesting
existing work is that I think we found a
way that we can do all of this by just
leveraging the existing training work
that's already being done to train these
Cottle's so that's the anyway you work
the work that we're doing with Harvard
is with Professor James Mickens and he
has a student we're working with and
they're what we're trying to understand
is this question of can we really delete
a user's private data from a system
let's take a simple classical storage
system as an example suppose all the
person does it goes in and says insert
this data item into your storage system
like what happens and what we found it's
kind of fascinating to see that just one
thing that you insert into a storage
system all the different things it
touches like you have all this transient
state created you affect these global
parameters and state and then you put
the actual data into a data structure
that's the easy part right but there's
all these other kind of side effects
that happen maybe some of those
statistics that are used are used to
Train some kind of machine learning
model I mean there's all kinds of things
that can happen so we're trying to
basically track all that and in systems
we have this notion of taint tracking
which is like imagine you put a color on
the data and you see where the color
spreads so we have some techniques for
doing that in systems already but what
we're trying to understand is how do I
measure like how much I care about all
the things I've touched right like these
taint tracking things if you touch
something they're like oh it's it's
tainted but you know if I add one number
of mine that's a private number to like
a thousand other numbers do I really
care about what I've done there what
we're asking here in this work is also
like how do I reason about how much of
my privacy is being leaked which has
connections to differential privacy
actually how do I reason about how
sensitive my input is to whatever state
its affected and once I figure that out
and I decide okay I don't care about
this stuff because it really hasn't
affected things enough but I care about
this stuff because I've affected it in a
meaningful way then how do I go about
deleting that data it's not so clear how
we can in a generic way allow the entire
system to fully and completely delete
what it needs to delete when it comes to
that users private data
so another work-in-progress well it's
about now then I always ask what could
possibly go wrong
Sid and I do this because I want to know
that you have
the risk as well as the rewards
inherited research so while you frame a
lot of your work in terms of AI playing
nicely with humans are collaborating
with humans or helping humans is there
anything you can see down the line or
maybe are afraid you can't see down the
line so that's even worse that gives you
cause for concern or keeps you up at
night and if so what are you doing about
it I think that AI solutions will always
be held to a different standard then
human operators or human solutions I do
worry about what happens when even a
system that we deploy that has let's say
this kind of safeguard in place if
something goes wrong how do you react to
that what kind of policies do you put in
place to determine what to do in those
situations you know what happens when
one of these AI systems actually hurts a
person and this has happened in the past
right but you know when it does happen
it's it's interpreted very differently
then if the cause for that accident or
incident was driven by a human in a lot
of the applications we've looked at if
the safeguard gets violated a little bit
here and there it's actually okay and we
actually can leverage that and in the
work we do we do indeed leverage that
but what if it's not okay right what if
it's never okay for even the slightest
violation to happen how do we in those
situations still learn still do what we
need to do without the risk so that's
something that does worry me because it
makes me realize that there are some
things where you just don't want to
replace a human but I do believe that
this kind of hybrid approach we talked
about I think it will ensure that both
sides have an important role to play I
think what's happening is that AI is
showing us that we're not playing the
right role and so what we need to do is
just kind of adjust the role I'm not
worried about AI replacing creativity
and elegance I mean a lot of people are
worried about that I think there's just
too much like elegance and beauty and
the kinds of solutions humans come up
with and it's one of the reasons why I
spent a lot of time learning from and
using human solutions and all of the AI
work that I do I happen to know that you
didn't begin your career doing hybrid
systems reinforcement learning research
in New York City for MSR so what's your
story said how did you get where you are
today doing cutting-edge research in the
city that never sleeps
that's a good question I grew up in the
Philippines but I had a lot of exposure
to the US and other countries I grew up
in an international environment and I
went to college at MIT in Cambridge in
Massachusetts and I remember seeing a
student solve a problem that we had been
assigned in a way that he wasn't told
how to solve it and it's kind of blew my
mind which is a little sad if you think
about it and why did you do it that way
when they told us to do this man you
know we were too figured it out if you
did it that way why did you do it that
way but that resulted in a new idea that
led to a paper that he submitted and it
was I think at that point that I
realized my professors are not just
giving me problem sets that the stuff
that they're teaching me a stuff they
invented and that we have this ability
to kind of innovate new ways of doing
things even new ways of doing existing
things and I had not really realized
that or appreciate that until that point
all this time I'd been like you know
thinking of my professors is just people
who gave me problem sets but now when I
go back and look at them I realized that
I was taught by these amazing superstars
that I kind of took for granted and so
after I left college I went to Microsoft
to work in Windows Server actually for
three years I worked in a product room
as a developer but I always ended up
going back to thinking about the
algorithms and the ideas behind what we
were doing and you know I was fortunate
enough to have a good boss that let me
work on research II type things so I
would actually visit MSR and talk to em
azar people as an engineer from a
product team and ask them questions and
I always had this no respect for them I
always put them on a pedestal in my mind
I think this kind of inspired a more
kind of creative pursuit and so that's
why I went back to grad school and I
think the reason why I ended up at MSR
after doing my PhD is because MSR was
the one place where they really
appreciated my interdisciplinary and
slightly weird background right the fact
that I did some system stuff the fact
that I did some Theory stuff the fact
that I worked in the product group for
three years like they actually
appreciated a lot of those things and I
felt like this is a place where all of
that stuff will be viewed as a strength
rather than oh you're kind of good at
these things but you're really good at
one of these things more than the others
you know that kind of thing which is
something that does come up as an issue
in academia and even in our labs we
struggle with it and hiring people who
are at the boundary of disciplines who
are
cross-cutting because it's not so easy
to evaluate them how do you compare such
a person to another candidate who is an
expert in one area right how do we put a
value on this kind of interdisciplinary
style versus this deeper more siloed
style of research so it's not an easy
question it's been a recurring theme in
my life I would say said what's one
interesting thing that we don't know
about you that is maybe impacted your
life or career and even if it didn't
impact anything in your life or career
maybe it's just something interesting
about you that people might not suspect
so I was not a very typical Indian kid
growing up I grew up in the Philippines
and partly in India and I spent a lot of
time doing like hip-hop and breakdancing
and things that drove my parents a
little crazy I would say they would let
me do it as long as my grades didn't
suffer when I came to MIT I saw these
people doing a style of dance where they
didn't have to prepare anything it was
just like I do you know how square
dancing works yeah right you just follow
a color it calls all the moves and you
know I I joined that dance group and I
eventually became the president of that
group and that's actually where I met my
wife who was a PC student at the time in
a square dancing group no it was in a
salsa version of that kind of work so
it's called casino Rueda
it's like square dancing but it's a
collar based dance where the caller
calls on the move so I would call these
moves with hand signals and all that and
everyone does it and makes these
beautiful formations in patterns but
it's all it's all so so that was a very
important kind of part of my time at MIT
and I do appreciate the University a lot
because it gave me the ability to have a
balanced life there so that's something
kind of non-work-related that people
don't usually expect I guess something
work-related that people may not know so
much about me is that I don't really
like technology I'm not a very good user
or adopter of technology that I'm always
kind of behind and in fact I think I use
it when it becomes embarrassing that I
don't know about it and this has
happened repeatedly in the past so I do
a lot of things because I need to for my
work but I think this actually works to
my advantage
I don't like technology I don't like
like writing thousands and thousands of
lines of code I like thinking more about
how to do things minimally
finding the simplest and most elegant
route is really important to me one
thing that I have a big passion for is
is teaching if I'm honest with myself I
probably should be in a university
because I love working with students and
mentoring them I actually feel that
might be my greatest strength compared
to the other things that I do and one of
the things you need to be able to do
well if you want to teach a student is
explain something in the kind of
simplest way and of course it's a lot
easier to explain something in a simple
way if that thing is simple to begin
with right not only is it easy to
explain it's easier to code up it's
usually easier to program and that means
that it's less likely to have bugs and
other issues in it so there's a lot of
value to simplicity and it's something
that I think about all the time
really has permeated everything that I
do well it's time to predict the future
or at least dream about it so if you're
wildly successful what will you be known
for at the end of your career in other
words how do you hope your research will
have made an impact and what will we be
able to do at that point that we
wouldn't have been able to do before wow
that's a good one that's a tough one to
answer let me tell you two things that I
think would make me happy if at the end
of my career these things happened if
our world is run by AI systems that
operate in a harmonious way with humans
whose safety we are so assured of that
we take it for granted if a part of that
can be attributed to the work that I've
done that would make me happy so that is
that is one thing the other thing though
which may even be more important to me
is that if I'm remembered as someone who
was you know a good teacher or a good
mentor so if for example if my ideas are
being taught to undergraduates or even
better if they're being taught to high
school students I think the further down
you go the more fundamental and the more
basic the more simple the stuff is to me
that's you know a sign of greater impact
on education so I've had a bit of a
taste of that when I was in my PhD I did
some work on very classical data
structures and we came up with some new
ones and those are being taught to
undergraduates now and they're in
textbooks now and that kind of thing
makes me really happy you know I hope
that by the end of my career that big
chunks of my work
or even parts of it will be taught to
undergraduates or even better talk to
high school students to me that would
make me super happy said son thank you
for joining us today on the podcast it's
been terrific Thank You Gretchen I
really appreciate it to learn more about
dr. siddhartha sin and how researchers
are working to optimize decision-making
in real-world settings visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]